Land und Brecht
[Musik]
schönen guten Morgen Richard schönen
guten Morgen Markus hoffe es geht dir
gut ja wollte heute mit dir mal über das
sprechen was im Morgengrauen ist 24
Februar
2022 passiert ist wir alle werden diesen
Morgen nicht vergessen da hat Putin die
Ukraine angegriffen dass deutete sich
über Wochen an fast genau ein Jahr her
seitdem haben wir ja unfassbar viel Leid
gesehen wir haben große Überraschungen
erlebt wir haben diese wahnsinnige
Tapferkeit der Ukraine auf der einen
Seite dieser schreckende Schwäche die
Korruption auf der Seite der russischen
Armee gesehen diese Abgebrühtheit wenn
es darum geht auch Zivilisten
umzubringen zu vergewaltigen zu morgen
ich habe mit Paul ronsheimer schöne
Grüße an der Stelle der ist gerade
wieder in Kiew
vor zwei Tagen gesprochen gesagt die
Russen sterben immer noch in Massen im
Verhältnis 5 zu 1 ungefähr also da gibt
es ein Blutvergießen auf beiden Seiten
frage ich mich wie man wie man auf diese
Zahlen also wenn ich eins gelernt habe
in diesem ein Jahr ich glaube überhaupt
keinen Zahlen ich glaube gar keine also
ich es gibt die Zahl des
US-amerikanischen generalstaatschefs der
sprach von 200.000 Toten und schwer
verletzten 100.000 auf Seiten der Russen
100.000 auf Seiten der Ukraine du
zitierst jetzt ronsheimer Verhältnis 1
zu 5 dann gibt es die Ukraine
veröffentlicht immer irgendwelche Zahlen
von die präzise genau wie viele
russische Soldaten getötet worden ist wo
ich mich immer gefragt habe wer zählt
die an welcher Stelle wo macht man das
ja Drohnen Drohnen die wissen die wissen
sehr viel also ich finde jetzt erfahren
von Sönke Knights diesen Militär
morgen auf Video angeguckt schätze den
absolut
und der gesagt hat der ukrainische
Generalstab von ukrainische Militär gibt
fast überhaupt keine verlässlichen
Informationen heraus auch nicht an den
Westen
das heißt er sagt wir sind besser
informiert über die Zustände der
russischen Armee als der ukrainischen
und er will sagt meint selbst die NATO
zum Beispiel wäre nicht gut informiert
darüber und deswegen gehe ich mal
einfach davon aus dass wir die
wirklichen Opferzahlen auf beiden Seiten
überhaupt nicht genau kennen aber das
einzige was ich mir vorstellen kann ist
dass es einfach unsägliches Leid ist und
wenn wir mal diesen Richtwert nehmen von
200.000 Toten und schwer verletzten die
von denen die Amerikaner sprechen dann
ist das einfach schon ungeheuerlich viel
ja ist es ich ich will nur darauf hinaus
wenn du sagst wir sind über die Zahlen
der Russen besser informiert das ist
glaube ich unbestritten nach diesem
einen Jahr das ist speziell auf Seiten
der Russen der die schicken dann immer
diese menschlichen Wellen da rein ist ja
auch gerade das was sie jetzt wieder
machen soll als als Kriegstaktik und
unter der sterben einfach unfassbar
viele Menschen und dann kommen einfach
immer wieder neue nach und ob es dann am
Ende drei zu eins vier zu eins oder fünf
zu eins ist jedes einzelne davon ist
eine Tragödie ich wollte aber noch was
anderes ganz genau sichert es gibt immer
es ist ja noch nicht wirklich Jahrestag
24 Februar aber es gibt einen anderen
Jahrestag neben diesem 24 Februar ein
Datum von dem ich ja glaube dass wir es
immer noch zu wenig im Blick haben wenn
es um diesen Krieg geht und auch um die
Frage wo ist irgendwann mal die Lösung
wann hört das endlich auf und das ist
der vierte Februar Olympische Spiele
Peking was ich ob du dich daran
erinnerst da gibt es dieses irre Bild da
sitzen diese zwei Männer Putin und
hierhin in diesem fast leeren Stadion
und und schauen sich Olympische Spiele
an und schwören sich kurz davor eine no
limits friendship
und wenn man sich damit mal vielleicht
können wir das heute im Laufe dieser
dieses Gesprächs noch mal machen mit den
Chinesen mal ein bisschen
angehender beschäftigt dann kommt man
dahinter dass da an diesem vierten
Februar da ist viel viel mehr passiert
als wir eigentlich so wahrgenommen haben
es war ja immer die große Frage
dass die Chinesen den Russen einen
Freibrief für den Angriffskrieg auf die
Ukraine auseinander okay
nein nein nein nein nein nein okay aber
die das ist ja hoch umstritten und es
war auch niemand im Raum außer den
beiden aber ich höre von Leuten die sich
damit beschäftigen die sagen die
Forschung geht mittlerweile eher davon
aus dass ich ihn pink zumindest eine
Idee hatte dass da was passieren würde
und dass sie dann aber und das wiederum
spricht eben deutlich dagegen dass sie
wirklich über das Ausmaß die Dimension
informiert waren sehr interessant die
die Chinesen haben ungefähr eine Woche
gebraucht bis sie eine Sprache eine
klare Position zu diesem Krieg gefunden
haben die haben ja erstmal auch begonnen
mit der Evakuierung von von Leuten aus
ihrer Botschaft in Kiew und so weiter
also das heißt das hat die auch kalt
erwischt nicht in Ihrem Interesse das
kann man vielleicht zu allgemein sagen
ich habe ja in dem Buch von Frank
sieieren über China gelernt dass die
Chinesen ganz großen Stil in der Ukraine
investieren investiert haben muss man
jetzt vielleicht zu einem das gilt für
die Häfen und das gilt sehr im großen
Stil für die Infrastruktur was übrigens
auch in anderen osteuropäischen Ländern
auch in EU-Ländern ja machen in Ungarn
zum Beispiel und ja gut ich meine jetzt
auch gerade eben diese osteuropäischen
Länder die Ungarn oder so die wir als
problematische
EU-Mitgliedstaaten sehen Serbien ja und
die wird dann ganz große Geschäfte in
der Ukraine und wenn ich sie ihren
richtig verstanden habe hat er mir
versucht zu erklären dass ich in diesen
überhaupt kein Interesse an diesem den
Krieg haben ja also sie waren gegen den
Krieg und zweitens dass sie kein
Interesse daran haben dass der Westen
diesen Krieg gewinnt und die Ukraine
dann quasi Teil Europas wird und damit
vielleicht nicht mehr so idealer Partner
für dich Chinesen und dass sie kein
Interesse an einem russischen Sieg haben
weil dann ist das für sie auch weg
und ich denke mal da wird einiges dran
sein weil dieses Investitionsvolumen in
die Ukraine war enorm ich weiß gar nicht
ob überhaupt ein anderes Land so viel in
der Ukraine in den letzten Jahren
investiert hat wie China
interessant ist ja
was da in diesem Dokument drinsteht ne
indem sie sich diese diese große
Freundschaft sozusagen schwören oder
diese no limits friendship beschwören
ich habe mir das mal angesehen das sind
so ungefähr 14 Seiten das ist sehr
interessant dass das das die Sprache die
es zum Teil wirklich eskalativ dies
aggressiv da steht drin die NATO soll
gefälligst aufhören sich immer weiter zu
erweitern umgekehrt sichert man
sozusagen sich die russische
Gefolgschaft zu wenn es um Taiwan geht
und sagt das ist ein großes China und
das ist für uns unverhandelbar aber
dieser Punkt mit der NATO z.B der
Hinweis darauf dass Staaten souverän
sind dieser Sound der sagt unsere
Demokratie reden von ihrer eigenen
Demokratie ist
meisten so gut wie eure das ist schon
sehr sehr interessant und dann bricht
dieser Krieg aus und am Anfang gibt es
da keine richtige Sprache das hat die
offensichtlich überrascht aber dann sagt
gibt es irgendwann einen Moment der sagt
eine Sprecherin der chinesischen
Regierung vielleicht erinnerst du dich
daran die sagt was habt ihr denn
erwartet wenn man ein so großes Land so
in die Ecke drängt wie Russland und an
die Wand stellt sozusagen die Wand
drückt was habt die denn erwartet das
heißt dieses narrativ diese Erzählung
ist identisch mit dem russischen exakt
die Russen die sozusagen vom vom Bösen
Westen in die Welt werden Krieg als
selbstverteidigungskriegen
groß macht imperialkrieg ja und durch
die chinesische Brille
es ist richtig was du sagst es gab dann
wenig später nach einer Woche haben sie
dann darauf hingewiesen und gesagt na ja
wir sind ja ein friedliebendes Land und
wir wollen dass die miteinander reden
jetzt gab es gerade wieder die
diplomatische Eskalation vor wenigen
Tagen irgendwo alle Sprecherin sagte die
Amerikaner sollen mal aufhören hier
Waffen zu liefern weil die sind es
eigentlich die anderen Interesse an
diesem Krieg haben das heißt da gibt es
schon eine sehr kalte Abwägung glaube
ich die die einfach sagt okay was nützt
uns das ich glaube auch dass diese
Freundschaft in Wahrheit nicht gibt im
Zweifel lassen die die Russen fallen wie
eine heiße Kartoffel ja also die
Tatsache dass der dass das Putin
heiraten genau
gut aber es war in den letzten Jahren
besser als dieser verheerende Zustand
immer früher hat also man stand sich ja
schon mal militärisch seiner Mann
schurei ganz übel gegenüber also
zwischen Maro und der so wird Union
bestandene totfeindschaft und das sind
auch jetzt eher so der was soll man
sagen unliebsam adoptivgeschwister und
es ist keine keine Liebe
kleine Bruder genau aber die die Sicht
durch die chinesische Brille ist
wirklich interessant Notfall durch die
chinesische Brille gesehen würde ich
sagen das ist den nicht so ganz unrecht
das ist da jetzt jemanden gibt Putin der
den Westen in dieser Art und Weise
beschäftigt der uns auch schwächt das
kostet uns alles sehr sehr viel Geld das
kostet auch die Amerikaner sehr viel
Geld also dass das ist durchaus etwas
glaube ich von dem die Chinesen ganz
kalt abwägend sagen lass mal gucken was
da passiert
reine informationsfrage weil ich das
nicht genau weiß und weil ich da
widersprüchliches höre aus
US-amerikanischer Perspektive
lohnt sich der Krieg ökonomisch oder ist
er ökonomisch ein großes Problem also
ich war ich spring mal das Argument für
eins ist gefüllte Auftragsbücher der
Rüstungsindustrie die ja für die USA
bedeutender ist als ihr Autoindustrie
für Deutschland mit Abstand die größte
und wichtigste Industrie und natürlich
profitiert die von Kriegszeiten und wer
jetzt alles in der Welt amerikanische
Waffen bestellt das müsste ja eigentlich
wirtschaftlichen enormer Gewinn sein und
dagegen spricht und das ist vielleicht
auch der Grund warum damals das Wort of
trust dies der New York Times ne den
beiden so gegrillt hat genau ja dass die
internationale Finanzwelt und
möglicherweise auch sagen weil die
Hightech Welt des Silicon Valley oder
sowas an dieser Konfrontation überhaupt
keine Interesse haben weil die absolute
globalisierungs- und Freihandels
Befürworter in der ganzen Welt sind also
davon profitieren die größer die Märkte
sind je mehr Bewegung da ist je weniger
direkt Auseinandersetzung ist umso
besser also ich habe das Gefühl die
Frage ob Amerika unter dem Strich
wirtschaftlich profitiert oder nicht die
ist gar nicht einfach total
interessanter Punkt Richard ich habe
darüber heute morgen mal mit Janker
Oertel gesprochen schöne Grüße an der
Stelle die ich sehr schätze beschäftigt
sich viel mit China sehr kluge Frau die
sagte auf genau diese Frage weil das ja
einer der zentralen Vorwürfe ist wenn
man so das große Bild mal sich anschaut
und wir versuchen das ja heute auch so
dieses eine diese eine Erzählung die es
immer gibt na ja also die Amerikaner die
profitieren ja davon am allermeisten
dass dieser Krieg nicht aufhört und im
Westen andere auch und die Aktie von
rein Metall und so weiter
deutsches Unternehmen
aber ich will nur sagen deswegen sagte
ich andere auch also die profitieren
alle davon sie sagte Dresden mal um
überlegt mal wer das bezahlt
und das stimmt natürlich was stimmt ist
die Waffen die die Amerikaner jetzt in
die Ukraine liefern wir bezahlt die die
Ukraine nicht sondern die bezahlte
amerikanische Steuerzahler
diese Waffen eigentlich nur sozusagen
geliehen oder geliest also müsst muss
das nicht irgendwann zurückgezahlt
werden sind die alle wirklich geschenkt
ob die geschenkt sind oder nicht aber
erstmal müssen sie produziert werden und
bezahlt werden
irgendwann später wenn die also die EU
wird ja nach dem kriegen wir gehen mal
fest davon aus dass die Ukraine nach
diesem Krieg noch existiert ja das ist
jedenfalls unser aufnung und dann würdet
wird sie mit unglaublichen Summen
wahrscheinlich dreistelligen
Milliardenbeträgen vielleicht Billionen
Betrag oder sowas wieder aufgebaut und
dann gäbe es ja die Möglichkeit die
Schulden die man hat ja die wegen der
Waffenlieferung zurückzuzahlen einem
sich Optionsscheine auf das Erdgas was
man einem Schwarzen Meer hat oder
Firmenbeteiligungen oder was weiß ich
was oder so also mir ist bislang nicht
klar aber das ist ich weiß das auch
nicht ich habe auch nichts Gutes darüber
gefunden und gelesen diese Waffen sind
meines Wissens nicht einfach alle
geschenkt das kann ich mir auch nicht
vorstellen ich weiß es schlicht nicht
aber ich kann mir trotzdem vorstellen
das kostet eine Volkswirtschaft erstmal
Geld was da jetzt gerade passiert und
das schwächte uns und das ist durch die
chinesische Brille gesehen glaube ich
nicht uninteressant es ist auch
interessant mal hin zu gucken ich habe
dann als Gegenargument gebracht und
gesagt na ja so wie Du ja diese
Militärmaschine die die die die
amerikanische vor allen Dingen das ist
ja auch ein großer Technologietreiber ja
absolut genauso wie in Israel z.B in
Israel einer der Gründe warum es dort so
eine lebendiges Start-up-Szene gibt ist
genau diese israelische Militärmaschine
ja das heißt die treiben technologische
Entwicklungen voran und so weiter und
ich glaube wir haben auch schon mal hier
drüber gesprochen es gibt ja eine
direkte Verbindung
zwischen dem Pentagon und den großen
tech-giganten im Silicon Valley aufs
engste miteinander
die Entwicklung zum Internet hin und so
weiter das sind alle nicht nicht denkbar
ohne strategische Förderung der sich die
US-amerikanischen Staates und das
Interesse des Militärs ganz genau was
auch erklärt ist auch total interessant
wissen glaube ich viele nicht warum die
sich niedertrauen mal eine rote Linie zu
setzen wenn der amerikanische Staat
kommt und sagt ich will aber eure Daten
ne da gibt es da gibt es Verbindungen
und Querverbindungen
von Anfang an da war also das Silicon
Valley ist unter anderem im Interesse
des amerikanischen Militärs und das
staatliche Förderung entstanden richtig
ne also das ist nicht irgendwann mal
später dass die Geheimdienst und die
Militärs dazu gekommen sind sondern von
Anfang an mit dem Boot und wann das
wahnsinnig spannend was dahinter stand
ja zum Beispiel auch ne der Flug zum
Mond ja erkenne die und so weiter das
fing da alles quasi an Janka Oertel sagt
das sehr interessant sie sagt im Kalten
Krieg war das so sagt heute sind die so
unabhängig heute geht technologischer
Fortschritt so schnell voran dass du
eigentlich das Militär dafür gar nicht
mehr brauchst sie sagt es ist eher
umgekehrt und macht er ein sehr gutes
Beispiel Drohnen die kommen aus der aus
aus dem zivilen Bereich und irgendwann
hat das Militär die Möglichkeit von
Drohnen erkannt und sagt okay pass auf
dann nehmen wir das jetzt doch auch mal
um z.B Aufklärung oder oder sogar
Geschosse zu transportieren Raketen zu
transportieren wie wir es jetzt auch im
Ukraine Krieg sehen also das ist sehr
interessant aber der der die Frage
welches Interesse die Chinesen auch an
diesem Krieg kam ich habe das Gefühl
nach einem Jahr das ist immer noch
deutlich unterbelichtet und sie gaukeln
der Welt vor da gibt es so eine
Neutralität aber die gibt es nicht
ich ich weiß aus vielen Gesprächen
mittlerweile ich erinnere mich an
Norbert Röttgen der das zu einem sehr
frühen Zeitpunkt schon sagte die Mission
damit die versorgen die russische
Rüstungsindustrie mittlerweile mit mit
einer gigantischen Menge von Halbleitern
Chips die sie selber herstellen können
hat sich verdoppelt die Russen wiederum
profitieren von den Chinesen weil sie
Erdöl an die verkaufen die kaufen das
dann ziemlich günstig ein verticken ist
dann teilweise auf dem Weltmarkt wieder
weiter das ist alles unglaublich perfide
und es ist sehr schwer an diese Zahlen
ranzukommen weil die Russen mit Beginn
des Krieges aufgehört haben
handelszahlen und Bilanzen zu
veröffentlichen das heißt es gibt so
eine so ein so hat sie mir das erklärt
so eine ganze Wissenschaft dann ganz ist
die Partner dass ich eigentlich
mittlerweile darum kümmert
über Zahlen anderer Länder indirekt dann
schließen zu können was die Russen
eigentlich wirklich handeln und was da
wirklich passiert und Sie wissen
daraufhin dass es zum Beispiel auch aus
chinesischer Sicht und dann höre ich
auch auf einen gerade eine interessantes
Experiment gibt die meist gehandelte
Währung an der Moskauer Börse ist der
Hyänen die chinesische Währung
mittlerweile und die Idee sozusagen da
mal was auszuprobieren ja die die die
die Chinesen haben ja Angst irgendwann
mal wenn sie überziehen an der harte
Dollar Sanktion zum Beispiel zu kriegen
ja wie handelst du dann ja nur zwei
Komma fünf Prozent glaube ich das
gesamten Welthandels laufen über die
chinesische Währung alles andere ist
Dollar und Euro dominiert aber vor allen
Dingen Dollar dominiert das heißt jetzt
mal zu gucken was passiert wenn wir
unsere Rohstoffe Erdöl z.B russisches
Erdöl jetzt plötzlich in unserer eigenen
Währung handeln die eigene Währung
dadurch viel wichtiger zu machen neue
Handels bis man sagen Routinen zu
entwickeln glaube das ist alles sehr im
chinesischen Interesse und deswegen
stimmt diese Geschichte mit wie halten
uns da völlig raus wir sind neutral die
Geschichte das ist Märchen ja gut also
wie kann man als als Großmacht und als
Wirtschaft Supermacht China ist
eine völlig neutrale Position in so
einer Situation haben das ist ja klar
dass sie das nicht haben also positiv
kann man sagen die Chinesen haben diesen
Krieg mit Sicherheit nicht vom Song
gebrochen nein und ähm die Chinesen
wollen und das war das was ich vorhin
gesagt habe dass keine Seite gewinnt die
wollen auch nicht dass die Russen
gewinnen aber sie wollen um alles in der
Welt nicht dass die Russen verlieren
weil der Westen ja die das Zeitalter
einer quasi bipolaren Weltordnung
ausgerufen hat das kann man sagen es ist
sozusagen die zeitenwände in groß
besteht daran dass man sagt so was
ergänzt the rest und sowas ist ein
allererster die nicht China und dann
anderen Länder die stark mit China
assoziiert sind und das ist zunehmend
Russland und es ist ja oft genug gesagt
worden der Krieg mit all den Folgen
führt zu einer Verhärtung der Blöcke und
die Verhärtung der Blöcke besteht darin
dass sich China und Russland die sich
eigentlich nicht besonders mochten immer
näher und näher und näher kommen das ist
eine Folge dieses Krieges richtig und
das ist eine Folge von der China
wahrscheinlich wesentlich stärker
profitiert als Russland was ist alles so
aber man darf nicht vergessen die
Chinesen haben diesen Kriegen und
wirklich nicht begonnen provoziert
wir versuchen
gerade dieses Krieges weißt du wer uns
noch einen Nutzer ist
Kim Jong-un
weil von dem keiner mehr redet
weil der das hat ja gar nicht ich glaube
der mag das immer gern wenn die Welt
wenn man über ihn redet meinst du ne ich
glaube tatsächlich dass der einer der
großen nutznießer ist so beschreiben es
Leute die sich da wirklich gut auskennen
und sagen der ist jetzt echt ganz
ernsthaft an China ran gerückt ja die
die haben überhaupt kein Interesse daran
dass der immer neue lustige Atomraketen
in die Luft schießt warum nicht weil sie
natürlich sehen dass rund um China herum
also südkorea Japan zum Beispiel das
pazifistische Japan die rüsten wegen
dieses Krieges gerade richtig auf weil
sie Angst haben vor dem was ich in pink
als nächstes macht ja was ist mit Teil
waren und alles mögliche und deswegen
haben die kein Interesse daran dass Kim
Jong-un Raketentest macht weil je mehr
der Raketen in die Luft schießt desto
bedrohter werden sich Südkoreaner
Japaner und andere fühlen und in der
Folge immer weiter auf wussten und China
möchte nicht von Leuten um Single sein
von Staaten und Single sein die denen
eigentlich feindselig gegenüberstehen
und die dann ihrerseits jetzt eine
richtige aufrüstungsspirale reinkommen
also da da passiert gerade was es ist
wirklich gefährlich du willst sagen die
Zeit der Narrenfreiheit für Nordkorea
ist vorbei
das weiß ich gar nicht die profitieren
auf jeden Fall davon ne also die die
Chinesen müssen die bei guter Laune
halten und und ich sag mal so ne wenn es
eine wenn du das mal vergleichst ist ja
auch total interessant
Nordkorea und die Ukraine immer
vergleichst also die Lehre auch nach
einem Jahr dieses Krieges ist doch wenn
du
Atomwaffen hast dann mach nicht den
Fehler und gibt sie weg ist das was die
Ukraine gemacht hat und wenn du keine
hast dann sorgt dafür dass du welche
kriegst ja gut
wäre genau der Geschichte von 1994 na
also Ukraine Abgabe der der Atomwaffen
wenn die Ukraine damals die Atomwaffen
nicht abgegeben hätte wäre sie als Staat
nie ernsthaft schon klar das war jetzt
nicht so als ob man da lange überlegt
hat machen wir das machen wir das nicht
nein das war eine Bedingung genau an die
Russland gestellt hat und ohne die wäre
die Unabhängigkeit nicht möglich gewesen
das muss man einfach dazu sagen deswegen
kann historischer Fehler es gab keine
Alternative total richtig aber die Lehre
daraus die zynische Lehre daraus ist
wenn du Atomwaffen hast dann dann kann
die im Grunde nichts passieren das ist
das worauf sich jemand wie Kim Jong-un
verlässt und das führt jetzt zu dieser
zu dieser Aufrüstung Spirale von der ich
glaube das kann auch sehr sehr
gefährlich werden ja da gibt's dann
neues Wettrüsten in Ostasien mit einem
sehr ungewissen Ausgang und der Auslöser
ist auch wieder das was vor einem Jahr
in der Ukraine Morgengrauen ist 24
heute das ist heute so wir haben ja
schon häufig über die Globalisierung
gesprochen ne und das ist heute wichtig
ist wenn in China und sakreis umfällt
und wenn es solche erschütterungen sind
wie der brutale russische Angriffskrieg
kann man sich vorstellen das ist in der
heutigen globalisierten Welt hat alles
Auswirkungen auf alles wir haben schon
häufig darüber gesprochen was das für
Afrika bedeutet ja im Augenblick
explodieren an den Börsen die
Weizenpreise ja das wird gigantische
humanitäre Katastrophen auslösen das war
das was man immer befürchtet hat wenn
der Krieg lange geht ja dann wird das zu
Hungerkatastrophen in Afrika führen wir
sind auf weiter dabei genau das zu
provozieren
die meisten getreideschiffe haben wir
auch darüber geredet die die Ukraine
verlassen verlassen sie nicht in
Richtung Afrika da werden sie
gigantische Katastrophe als Folge des
Ukraine Krieges entstehen und so könnten
wir eigentlich die ganze Folge nur
darüber reden was sekundär Folgen ja
dieses genau 24 stimme Dir völlig zu
Richard nur bei einer Formulierung
stimme ich Dir ausdrücklich nicht zu
sagst du wir provozieren das wir haben
diesen Krieg nicht provoziert wenn du
vorhin sagst die Chinesen haben diesen
Krieg nicht vom Zaun gebrochen wir waren
es auch nicht wir haben den Krieg nicht
vom Zaun gebrochen das habe ich auch
keine Zeit gesagt Gott will um Gottes
Willen nein aber wir wir sind indirekte
Kriegspartei wir sind keine direkte
kriegsverteiler sind indirekte
Kriegsparteien über die Ukraine
unterstützen und insofern sind wir ein
Teil dieses Krieges wie auch immer wird
jetzt die sorgfältige Formulierung nee
genau genau ich habe in dieser Woche so
oft an Dich gedacht ich denke immer an
dich wie du weißt aber wenn diese Woche
in dieser Woche besonders häufig und
zwar in zwei interessanten Stellen
die erste Stelle war die mit mit Lula
Scholz auf Brasilien Besuch es war ja
total interessant zu sehen wie diese
Erzählung
du erinnerst dich das was ich vorhin
gesagt habe die diese chinesische
Sprecherin gesagt was denkt ihr denn was
passiert wenn man so ein großes Land wie
Russland einfach so in die Ecke drückt
ja Lula der der brasilianische Präsident
ich mein Scholz fährt dahin geht um
Rohstoffe geht um Lithium ja geht wir
wir brauchen Lithium in den nächsten
Jahrzehnten in einem unvorstellbaren
ausrichtet haben wir auch schon häufiger
darüber gesprochen
Katastrophe nicht ausmalen weil Lithium
wird im so gewonnen ja das geht auch im
Augenblick gar nicht wirklich anders ja
wenn da diese diese Salz sehen da quasi
trocken gelegt werden und das Lied sie
um zu gewinnen dass der ganze Staub ja
der wird aber im Winter über die Felder
und das ist tot giftig und so weiter
aber das ist ein anderes Thema
lithium ist kein harmloses Thema genau
ist es gar nicht interessant wird auch
noch mal sein dann wie wir uns dazu
verhalten weil Lithium gibt es nach
meinem Wissen auch in Deutschland aber
wir werden es ähnlich machen wie bei den
seltenen Erden das war ja auch
interessant in vor ein paar Wochen sind
die Nordschweden er ist dann ja ich weiß
nicht erfunden worden war nicht wie
viele aber
wenn man sich damit selbst versorgen
kann nimmt eine Menge die gibt es
übrigens auch hier die könnten wir auch
hier abbauen nicht in diesem Ausmaß aber
wir könnten und weil auch das eine
gigantische umweltschweinerei ist
ähnlich wie beim Lithium sagen wir dann
lass das mal in Schweden machen haben
wir nichts mehr zu tun aber bitte in
unserem Telefon natürlich auch da
brauchen wir dann schon so das ist halt
so Lola ja also Scholz will eigentlich
die Brasilianer weißt du die haben noch
Munition für den Gepard
auch irre ist das irre die haben
Munition für geben die hätten wir gerne
um sie in die Ukraine zu schicken und
Dula sagt Mama nicht ja aber Chinesen
sind ja ein sehr sehr wichtiger
handelsfaden dafür Brasilien so außerdem
hat Lula sich damit versucht in eine
Position des Dritten zu bringen sich zu
sagen wir sind wirklich neutral und als
wirklich neutrale könnten wir im Forum
bereitstellen für Verhandlungen das
Problem ist ja erinnerst dich früher gab
es ja noch Frankreich und Deutschland
als ein solches Forum mit Minsk Abkommen
genau und heute sind wir
vollkommen klar definiert nicht nur
moralisch humanitär auf Seite der
Ukraine sondern eben auch militärisch
deswegen können wir die Vermittlerrolle
nicht mehr einnehmen und wir sind ja die
ganze Zeit verzweifelt auf der Suche ja
wir haben Erdogan sowas machen kann ja
zudem werden wir nun auch kein wirklich
entspanntes Verhältnis haben und nun
bietet sich Brasilien an nicht als Staat
alleine ja sondern quasi als
als Host für für Verhandlungen und oder
als Basis und das ist ja schon mal gut
ich meine alles was an Verhandlungen
möglich ist muss irgendwann ausgenutzt
werden weil Einsatz stimmt mit
Sicherheit ja auch wenn Ihnen der
dämlichen gesagt hat ja aber jeder Krieg
endet mit Verhandlungen und irgendwann
ich meine ich glaube tatsächlich mal
unter uns ich bin sicher es wird die
ganze Zeit verhandelt
also es wird nicht verhandelt sozusagen
dass man kurz vor Abschluss irgendeines
Friedens steht ja aber das ist
diplomatische Kanäle gibt deutscher
Botschafter in Moskau und so weiter wo
also sich ständig ausgetauscht wird über
diese Dinge das kann ich mir gar nicht
anders vorstellen dafür wenn diese Leute
ja auch bezahlt dass sie das machen wo
sind wir sehr sehr sehr weit und das
weiß ich auch von einer Lösung entfernt
ja also solange die Russen in dort jetzt
sind sich nicht das geholt haben was sie
sich holen wollen
werden die keine Verhandlungen eingehen
die werden vermutlich nicht mal den
gegenwärtigen Status Quo einfrieren das
war immer so meine Hoffnung bevor sie
die militärischen Erfolge der letzten
Wochen hatten die blutig bezahlt haben
aber bevor sie die hatten hatte ich
immer die Hoffnung dass man das
zumindestens für eine Weile einfrieren
kann aber im Augenblick ist ja
wahrscheinlich nicht mal das möglich
also ich glaube wir kommen ganz ehrlich
gesagt im Augenblick überhaupt nicht
mehr aus der Sache ich habe übrigens so
eine Theorie warum Lula den Scholz da so
hat abtropfen lassen
du musst die Nummer die brasilianische
Außenhandelsbilanz angucken 30 Prozent
der brasilianischen Exporte gehen wohin
nach China
und dann hast du da genau wieder dieses
Thema ich habe übrigens Richard
vielleicht vielleicht können wir darüber
mal reden
Ivan kastev den du sehr schätzt den du
schon getroffen hast in meiner Sendung
war als ganzer Sendung war es eine tolle
Sendung ja mega mega muss man sich
angucken Mediathek wirklich großartig es
gibt auch so ein wunderbares Buch von
denen das Licht das erlosch
das ist ein Knaller Buch an bulgarischer
ist bulgarisch
genau intellektuell lassen ein toller
Typ der sagt ja wie endet dieser Krieg
der sagt ähm Kriege sterben einfach
Kriege Enten an der Wahlurne die in 2024
ist in Russland Wahl 2024 ist in Amerika
Wahl und krasse sagt das könnte etwas
mit diesem Krieg machen glaubst das auch
ja das glaube ich tatsächlich nun wissen
wir ja in den USA noch gar nicht wer
gegen wen Antrieb auf das wirklich
beiden gegen Trump ist oder ob es auf
beiden Seiten jemand anders ist also
wenn man wenn ich bei einer Mikrofon
sehe dann denke ich mir immer der wird
sich keine weitere Amtszeit mehr zumuten
und ob Trump tatsächlich also das alles
übersteht und und dann am Ende dann doch
noch mal da irgendwie wie so ein wie so
ein zehnmal angezählter Boxer wieder
aufsteht kann ich mir auch so ganz auch
nicht vorstellen obwohl man das bei dem
nie weiß da muss man mit allem rechnen
ne aber der hat ja schon erzählt er
würde den Krieg schnell zu Ende bringen
das wäre vermutlich auch so ja also ja
ich vermute der wird im Deal finden ja
also ich meine irgend dreckigen Deal
eingehen ich will mir den jetzt gar
nicht vorstellen wie der aussieht aber
das könnte ich mir vorstellen das könnte
auch sein dass bis 2024 die USA kriegst
müde sind möglich ist das aber das wäre
schlimm Richard ne hast du mal überlegt
weil ich meine nicht gesagt dass ich mir
den Deal von Trump jetzt als nächstes
wünschen ich wollte doch was anderes
hinaus ich wollte dich nicht hier
irgendwie eine komische Ecke drücken ich
wollte nur sagen und das den Satz das
wäre schlimm kann man auch missverstehen
ich will nur sagen stell dir mal für
eine Sekunde vor wir
unterstützen die Ukraine jetzt nicht
oder die Ukraine können nicht mehr die
rekrutieren mittlerweile über 60-Jährige
dann geht die Munition aus den geht das
Personal aus den wir in die Kämpfer
schlicht untergreifend aus das ist alles
sehr sehr bitter und dass die diesen
Krieg nicht verlieren das ist alles
andere als eine ausgemachte Sache egal
wie wir unterstützen oder also die Frage
nicht wissen ist was die Niederlage wäre
das kann genau also es gibt zwei
denkbare Niederlagen die eine Niederlage
ist die Russen holen sich das was sie in
Don jetzt noch nicht haben und was sie
in saporisha noch nicht haben ja und
errichten dann einen irgendwie eine
entsprechende Mauer und sagen wir
schießen euch weiter rund und wie wenn
ihr nicht uns garantiert dass er nicht
in die NATO geht und nun militärische
Obergrenze festlegt eine kleine Variante
die große Variante ist natürlich wenn
das ukrainische Militär tatsächlich
besiegt sein sollte ja dass man dann das
macht was man wie ich vermute von Anfang
an in dem Umfang nicht vor hatte aber
dass man dann bis hier wieder
durchmarschiert das ist aber auch die
Frage ob man das der russischen
Bevölkerung zumuten könnte weil das für
eine Belagerung von hier dass man sich
alles gar nicht ausmalen das war ja beim
ersten Mal ein halber Scheinangriff muss
man sagen also sind halbherzige Angriffe
aber mein Gesetz im Fall die Amerikaner
also da gab es diesen komischen konvo
der sich da nicht von der Stelle bewegte
Angriffe Angriffe auf Flughäfen im
Norden von Kiew aber die Hölle von Kiew
ja von dir die Bild-Zeitung jeden Tag
getitelt hat also dann wenn ich an die
kriegshöhle von Dresden denke oder wenn
ich einen kriegshöhle von Tokio und
Zweiten Weltkrieg denke das ist es
bislang nicht gewesen das würde es aber
dann werden genau ich denke das wissen
auch deswegen halte ich diesen diesen
diese sozusagen diese kleinere diesen
kleineren Sieg wahrscheinlicher als den
großen aber weiß man
mal zu Ende gedacht ne was wäre denn
sozusagen die Konsequenz also die Russen
besiegen die Ukraine was übernehmen die
dann dann übernehmen die einen völlig
geschundenes Land
völlig zerstörten ständig ich sehe nicht
das kann ich mir gar nicht vorstellen
die können die Russland kann den
Wiederaufbau der Ukraine gar nicht
machen deswegen kann ich mir eben auch
nicht vorstellen dass sie das ganz wer
will denn das kaputte Land dann völlig
ausgeblutete Land das mit der
Kriegswirtschaft jedes Jahr 30%
schrumpfen das Bruttoinlandsproduktes so
viele junge Menschen der jüngeren
Generation verloren all die Traumata die
Kriegsschäden die zerstörten Häuser wer
will denn das haben in dem Sinne als das
sozusagen dass der Eroberer sich das
unter Nagel reißt deswegen halte etwas
wahrscheinlicher also ohne Ahnung zu
haben niemand weiß es ja wir reden
gegenüber gerne selber nicht ja das
glaube ich auch also
dass das alles sowieso nicht zu Ende
gedacht ist aber dann ist es vermutlich
wahrscheinlicher dass das Ziel nicht
darin besteht die gesamte Ukraine
einzusacken ist eine Mutmaßung ja aber
ich kann es mir nicht wirklich
vorstellen ich habe mir das nur mal so
zu Ende überlegt wenn wenn das passieren
würde und das war ja offenkundig
zumindest am Anfang noch mal der Plan
dann übernimmst du dieses geschundene
Land und dann hättest du einen
jahrelangen jahrzehntelangen
Partisanenkrieg die Ukraine würden sich
bis zum Schluss immer weiter immer
weiter Generationen weiter immer wieder
wären das wäre das wäre katastrophale
nicht vorstellen also ich kann mir nicht
vorstellen dass jemand so bekloppt ist
dass er das ernsthaft und noch mal
überlegt dir meine Belagerung von KEF
mit all dem was das bedeutet ich glaube
nicht wirklich aber ich weiß es nicht
leider ja wenn ich weiß auch keinen der
das weiß nee nee die aber man muss ja
Szenarien denken die die große Frage
Richard nach nach diesem einen Jahr ist
für mich
immer noch die Frage nach dem Motiv wir
haben uns ja oft darüber unterhalten das
kann man auch häufig lesen dass
eigentlich Kriege dieser Art ich meine
wir reden wieder darüber dass Panzer
durch die Gegend fahren wir dachten doch
alle dass sie sowas von Retro das macht
kein Mensch mehr doch ja das ist ein
ganz traditioneller ekelhafter
brutaler Krieger mit teilweise mit
Stellungskriegen wie im ersten Weltkrieg
ganz furchtbar so und ich hatte diese in
dieser Woche eine sehr interessante
Begegnung an Gespräch noch mal dann noch
hinter den Kulissen mit Joe Käser dem
ehemaligen von Siemens interessanter
Mann sehr besonnen und der hat ein paar
kluge Dinge gesagt der hat Putin öfter
getroffen er hat in der Sendung
beschrieben wie er sozusagen Putin
dreimal neu kennengelernt hat der hat
vor zwei 14 an den Putin getroffen der
sehr offen gegenüber Deutschland war und
so weiter der Geschäfte machen wollte
der sein Land aufbauen wollte der dann
2014 und der bezeichnete es auch als
Fehler kurz nach der Annexion der Krim
Putin erneut getroffen und hat dann ganz
anderen Putin erlebt der jemand der
erstens das alles abgestritten hat und
dann den besten sowieso die Schuld dafür
gegeben hat und die nato-geschichte und
so weiter und dann zwei 19 wenn ich das
richtig im Kopf habe in Sotschi noch mal
getroffen und er hat mir erzählt noch
mal von dieser Begegnung und sagte das
war Wahnsinn das war ein Gespräch das
war angesetzt auf 20 Minuten ging dann
über eine Stunde und 50 Minuten lang
davon so war sein Gefühl
hat Putin einfach nur
besonders in beschimpft verbalen Müll
losgelassen über Merkel hergezogen über
den Westen hergezogen die NATO
hergezogen hat einen unfassbar wütenden
Mann dort getroffen und er sagt ihm dann
immer wieder Präsident wenn Sie ein
Problem mit der deutschen Kanzlerin
haben müssen sie mit der sprechen ich
bin da völlig falsche Ansprechpartner
ich bin hier für Siemens und dann sagte
er gab es diesen Moment indem er ihm
dann sagte wenn ihr nicht hier bei uns
ernsthaft Struktur aufbaut Siemens dann
schmeißen wir euch raus
und hat dann verwiesenes sehr
interessant wusste ich nicht siemens hat
eine große tiefe Verbindung zu Russland
jokese hat mir berichtet dass Werner von
Siemens und ich glaube sein Bruder Karl
die waren irgendwann in echten
Schwierigkeiten die waren eigentlich
pleite als sie das Unternehmen gegründet
haben
185054 so die Zeit herum und es war der
russische Zar der die damals mit
frischem Geld versorgt hat und dafür
gesorgt hat dass Siemens weiter
existiert deswegen gibt es in der
Unternehmenskultur von Siemens sozusagen
eine eine tiefe Verbindung zu Russland
und es war sozusagen bei denen die bei
Siemens das Sagen haben und die diese
historische Dimension überblicken am
Anfang das war ein schwerer Schritt für
die aus Russland wirklich komplett
rauszugehen weil sie kulturell einfach
mit denen wahnsinnig eng verbunden waren
über viele viele Jahrhunderte muss man
schon sagen und sehr interessant das war
mir so nicht klar aber sagte wir mussten
das dann jetzt machen das wäre gar keine
Frage aber diese diese Wut dieses Mannes
dieser Hass auf den Westen das hat den
wirklich beeindruckt genau und die
Erklärung dafür wäre das was krass der
ja sehr ausführlich ausgeführt hat dass
er sagt ein Geheimdienstler denkt in den
Kategorien von Loyalität und Fahrrad
genau und das ist quasi Putins
psychische DNA und weil die NATO
Ost-Erweiterung gekommen ist entgegen
dem mehr oder weniger
formulierten Versprechen in der NATO
Russland Akte 1997 hat Putin sich im
Anschluss verraten gefühlt das hat er
ganz deutlich auf der Münchner
Sicherheitskonferenz 2007 auch gesagt so
nach dem Motto wir hatten eigentlich
eine Abmachung ihr habt euch nicht dran
gehalten wir werden hier immer weiter
eingezelt und in dem gleichen Ausmaß man
kann ja sogar sagen parallel zur immer
weiteren Ausweitung der NATO verhärtete
sich das Herz Putins so mal diese
biblische Formulierung zu benutzen ja
das Herz das Herz Pharaos gegen gegen
die Israeliten also wir haben da quasi
eine parallele Entwicklung also mit dem
mit der Ausdehnung der NATO ja wird
verändert sich der Freundliche Putin aus
dem Bundestag in den Putin indem wir
heute kennen Schritt für Schritt
und das ist quasi so was ich
psychologisch abgespielt hat und wir
wissen ja auch von all den Leuten die
immer gewarnt haben ja also Helmut
Schmidt so an erster Linie und gesagt
hey russische Sicherheitsinteressen
berücksichtigen und wir können da nicht
einfach so und so weiter die NATO
wiederum hat damit argumentiert wenn
diese Schatten in die NATO hinein wollen
dann ist es die Hand souveränes Recht
und freier Entscheidung und wenn sich
von Russland halt bedroht fühlen ja wie
berechtigt auch immer jetzt würden wir
sagen hochberechtigt damals war das
nicht so berechtigt aus dann machen wir
das und das sind die beiden
Argumentationsstränge die sich bis heute
gegenüber stehen die einen die sagen ja
es ist deren Recht gewesen und siehe da
es war noch gut dass sie es gemacht
haben und die anderen die Sagen hätten
wir damit gar nicht erst angefangen dann
hätten wir diese ganze schicksalzhafte
Entwicklung die dazu diesen verheerenden
Katastrophe in der Ukraine geführt hat
nicht gekriegt und die Wahrheit ist doch
und das ist das was mich die ganze Zeit
gestört hat warum Stimmen der nicht
beide Geschichten
was ich gelernt habe im Laufe dieses
Jahres ist viel Geschichten zuzuhören ja
also keine alleinige Deutung des ganzen
vorzunehmen
wenn ich in Russland ich kann Russland
aus der Position betrachten die sagen
die NATO ostarbeiterung immer mehr
Territorium wir haben uns von der NATO
gedroht gesehen die Russen sehen in der
NATO ja nicht Deutschland die sehen die
USA die haben die die Zeit der der
Konfrontation der Blöcke nicht vergessen
die sehen sich jetzt vom Feind quasi
umzingelt so das ist eine
nachvollziehbare Geschichte
ist aber nicht die ganze Geschichte soll
die ganzen Geschichte gehört auch dass
die Sowjetunion ein Kolonialreich war
das eine Kolonien unmittelbar vor der
Haustür hatte
das waren alles russische Kolonien im
Grunde genommen wo die alles von Moskau
aus beherrscht ja nur die Waren direkt
vor der vor der Haustür und wie ein
Kolonialreich ja haben die Russen diesen
Anspruch das sind eigentlich wir das
gehört zu uns die sind vielleicht nicht
vollwertig wie wir aber die gehören uns
ja und wenn die dann ja amerikanische
Waffen einkaufen oder Geschäfte mit den
USA machen und so weiter dann denkt
Putin in dieser Kategorie Verrat und in
dem gleichen Ausmaß wie er sich
gedemütigt gefühlt hat durch die Natur
aus der Erweiterung im gleichen Maß
wurde er nationalsozialistischer
national revanistischer keimten groß
macht Fantasien auf ich weiß noch nicht
mal ob so sehr alleine in seinem Kopf
zumindestens in Russland und die
stärkste Opposition falls der Begriff
Opposition in Russland überhaupt erlaubt
ist ja das sind die nationaltoristen
das ist sozusagen die russische ultra
AFD das sind die Leute ja die ihn am
ehesten treiben können ja und Stück für
Stück hat er sich auch viel von deren
Gedankengut zu eigen gemacht und das ist
dieser Putin den wir heute erleben so
und wenn ich die Geschichte so erzähle
dann sehe ich sie immer von zwei Seiten
ich sehe sozusagen was ist sozusagen das
was es aus russischer Perspektive ist
und was ist es was ist aus westlicher
Perspektive ist und warum kann ich denn
nicht sagen es ist an dem was dran es
ist an dem was dann ach so ist das
passiert ohne das Werten zu müssen dann
habe ich jedenfalls eine halbwegs
logische Erklärung wie es zu diesem
Völkerrechtsbruch kam und zu diesem
Angriffskrieg ja ich halte das mit der
Natur ich halte das alles für ehrlich
gesagt für Hokus Pokus und für
Propaganda ähm musst dich mal daran
erinnern die wollten zeitweise sogar
selbst in die NATO
ähm aber das ist
der NATO den Zahn zu ziehen wenn man
selber teil
ich habe ich habe das Gefühl es geht
ganz handfest vielleicht auch noch um
was anderes die großer hat interessante
Theorie der sagt da ist ein Mann in
meinen Augen der ist nicht mal der
jüngste und der ist jetzt mit 70 Jahren
an einem Punkt an dem man sagen muss was
habe ich eigentlich erreicht es geht ums
Lebenswerk Russland ist wirtschaftlich
komplett am Abgrund die Transformation
Null funktioniert die Russen sind heute
ärmer als sie je zuvor waren und da
haben sie zu
den jetzigen Zeiten glaube ich eher
nicht aber man über alle gleich nein
aber
jedenfalls in der gleichen Zeitung
anguckt also ein postkommunistisches
Land ja China ist ja jetzt inzwischen
kapitalistisches Land ja mit mit
sozusagen kommunistischen Zuckerguss da
drüber irgendwie einen guten Stern auf
was drauf geklebt was ja sehr
kapitalistisches Staatskapitalismus ja
weitgehend aber eben wirklich kein
kommunistisches und wenn man sich diese
Erfolgsgeschichte anguckt und dann
parallel sich die Putin Geschichte
anguckt dann waren die ersten fünf Jahre
eigentlich auch eine Erfolgsgeschichte
mit weil sie nicht 45%
Wirtschaftswachstum und dann kommt die
große Stagnation dann kommt der Bruch
genau dann übernimmt sozusagen ein
mafiöses System übernimmt das ganze Land
ja und da werden Leute auf eine Art
obszöne Reich bis heute abend 20% war
schon vorher da das macht
ehrlichiöse System auch schon inseriert
Seiten da ja aber es entsteht ein neues
System mit Putin als Netz in als Spinne
im Netz ja und vorher war es sozusagen
anarchistisch oligarchisches System mit
Morgen und Auftragskillern und und
übelsten Form jetzt also man kann sagen
vielleicht die Mafia regiert und danach
reagiert die staatsmafia ja das ist gut
formuliert ich will nur darauf hinaus
bis heute ne also die Russen sind haben
viele Russen sind abends 20% die Russen
haben bis heute nicht mein Klo in ihrer
Wohnung oder in Ihrem Haus einfach nur
mal so darüber zu sprechen an meinen
niedriges pro-kopfeinkommen als als
Menschen in der Türkei und so weiter
also wenn du sagen das hat nicht
funktioniert und wenn du so viele
Rohstoffe hast so viel Erdöl hast so
viel Erdgas hast dann musst du dir doch
immer mal die Frage gefallen lassen was
zum Teufel hast du eigentlich mit diesem
ganzen Geld gemacht ist doch
unvorstellbar du hast nichts erreicht
und ähm ich glaube deswegen dass jemand
wie krass Def der sagt da geht's ganz
handfest um Staatsgebiet die Russen
haben jetzt 18 % des ukrainischen
Territoriums da geht es um Industrie da
geht es auch um Arbeit Sache eigentlich
was anderes
nun wirklich groß genug es gibt Leute um
Leute also
die Russen sind ein sterbendes Volk die
haben eine viel zu geringe
formierungsrate ja und sie werden allein
quantitativ immer unbedeutender das
wollte
Millionen Ukraine aber nicht das Land
also das ist die Kraft der These da hat
er ich glaube da hat er Recht der
demografische Faktor und der verweist ja
auf 2012 das sehr interessant 2012 vor
den Russland ein Gesetz verabschiedet
das ist Amerikanern verbietet russische
weißen Kinder zu adoptieren und es ist
total interessant weil ich glaube dass
das der Versuch ist zu verhindern dass
diese Kinder neue Ideen kennenlernen an
anderes westliches Leben kennenlernen
das ist zum Beispiel auch schon in den
90ern passiert erst die die Russen die
schwer reich geworden sind in den 90ern
wo haben die ihre Kinder hingeschickt in
den bösen bösen Westen die haben dort
ein ganz anderes Leben eine andere Form
von sexueller und auch sonst hier
Freiheit kennengelernt den man ganz ganz
anderes Leben
wahrscheinlich das Problem bestanden
aber dieses Gefühl so beschreibt es
krasseste das finde ich total gut
formuliert dieses Gefühl wir müssen
verhindern dass der Westen russische
Kinder
das das müssen wir stoppen ja und man
wollte sozusagen man fühlt sich in dem
Moment wie eine Entwicklungsland richtig
ja also Kinder werden aus armen Ländern
adoptiert ja und die Vorstellung dass
der Westen jetzt die Kinder aus Russland
das setzt wir auf eine Stufe ja mit
afrikanischen Ländern kann ich mir sehr
vorstellen dass das im russischen
national stolz aufs heftigste
widerspricht ja genau und dieses ja äh
custom spricht von einer identitätspanik
sagt da geht's darum sozusagen diesem
Bruch er sagte der Kommunismus war den
Russen egal zum Kommunismus hatten die
neben besonders sinnliches Verhältnis
ja haben die geliebt das war das war ihr
Land und das war dieses russische dieses
sowjetische Imperium wir sind ja wir
sind wir ganz genau
und ich ich habe ich habe musste so
denken als ich das hörte an Dimitri
glukowski den wir beide sehr mögen der
jetzt wieder bei uns in der Sendung war
und der mal diesen diesen tollen Text
geschrieben hat der Westen und wir wo er
sagt wir wussten dass ihr besser lebt
wir haben euch nachgeeifert wir haben
den Namen eurer Marken auswendig gelernt
aber für euch westla und das war das
Gefühl bis heute sind wir Menschen
zweiter Klasse ja gut und das ist das
gleiche Problem was es zwischen Wessis
und Ossis gibt ja hochziehen
als große kann man ja gar nicht sein
natürlich hatten wir ja also der der die
Menschen im Westen sehr weitgehend ein
starkes überlebenheitsgefühl genau
dass der Sowjet Mensch ne der ist
sozusagen gleich geschaltet und das ein
apparatschig und dazu die uralten Russen
Klischees ne Karl Marx hat mal gesagt
die Russen Tauben eigentlich nur zum zum
Saufen und Frauen vergewaltigen also es
gibt so ein ähnlichen Ausspruch von Karl
Marx ja ja also das war sozusagen das
das klassische Bild des Russen das ist
im Westen immer gegeben hatten als
primitives Volk ja ja und darunter haben
die die Russen sehr sehr stark gerissen
ja genau der der Lukowski Prinzip damals
irgendwie als als Gorbatschow den Fall
der Mauer durchfinkte da waren wir so
verzaubert dass wir dachten alle Mauern
stürzen jetzt auch ein alle anderen ja
und der beschreibt dann ist finde ich so
gut der Eiserne Vorhang hob sich und
zwei Welten die fast schwarz-weiße
sozialistische und die bunte
kapitalistische haben einander verdutzt
angeschaut wir wussten dass ihr besser
lebt aber wir hatten keine Ahnung um wie
viel besser ihr lebt und dann sagte aber
ihr wundert euch was da plötzlich mit
uns passiert ist was da geschehen ist
dass diese Begeisterung sozusagen in
Verachtung und eben jetzt den Hass
umgeschlagen ist und er sagt wir haben
ein Problem wir haben immer eure
Technologien wir haben eure Hamburger
wir haben eure Lebensweise bekommen aber
der Satz achtung das wurde uns immer im
Paket mit Werten übergeben mit einer
Ideologie mit einer Lebensweise das
heißt das Gefühl ist da kommt auch immer
mitgeliefert eine Bedienungsanleitung
wie ihr gefälligst jetzt auch zu werden
und zu leben hat vielleicht total
interessant ist interessant ich habe das
letzte Buch von Gorbatschow das ja vor
drei vier Jahren erschienen ist gelesen
weil ich war absolut neugierig wie er
Putin bewerten würde ja und es ist ja
völlig egal völlig bekannt dass sie sich
menschlich nicht mögen genau das ist
klar man hat man auch gesehen als
Gorbatschow gestorben ist und so also
wer so eine halbe Referenz die Putin da
gezollt hat weil aus russischer Sicht
Gorbatschow der große Verräter ist der
die die die groß macht so wird Union im
Westen preis gegeben hat ne das ist
quasi die der der das das tut ihnen
relativ für Gorbatschow aber
interessanterweise die Kritik die Putin
früher immer geäußert hat am besten ist
die gleiche hat auch was ist mit unseren
sicherheitspolitischen Interessen du
hast das gerade so abgetan weißt du die
NATO Erweiterung und da glaube ich nicht
für Firlefanz und so weiter die Frage
ist nicht
ob von der NATO Ost-Erweiterung für
Russland aus unserer Sicht eine reale
militärische Gefahr vorgeht das würden
wir verneinen ja die Frage ist ob das
die Russen genauso sehen mit einer
Geschichte die von Napoleon überrannt
worden sind die im Ersten Weltkrieg
überrannt worden sind von Deutschen und
im zweiten Weltkriegen nochmal die sehen
das anders und wenn man heißt
sicherheitspolitische Interessen
berücksichtigen dann heißt dass sich
zumindest zu verstehen die die andere
Seite tickt da musst du ganz ehrlich
sagen viel Mühe haben wir uns da nicht
gegeben ja da hast du recht du kennst
doch dieses Buch von Tim Marshall über
die Macht der Geographie das beginnt
genau mit diesem deswegen muss ich
gerade dran denken mit dem was du gerade
sagst
für Kind Kapitel Russland da ich putin
ist ein gläubiger Mensch nach allem was
man hört und ich glaube er betet
manchmal heimlich darum dass in der
Ukraine endlich Berge wachsen
ja was sagen will ist ja über diese
nordeuropäische Tiefebene über die
Ukraine kam die alle immer rein und
haben die einfach angegriffen und
überfallen so ist das und das ist eine
Grenze die ist so lang die kann man die
kann man konventionell kaum verteidigen
und da wir inzwischen eine Vorstellung
davon haben in welchem die solarten
Zustand sich die russische Armee
befindet jedenfalls für ein Land das ich
als militärische Großmacht versteht als
zweitstärkste der Welt und nun sehen wie
brüchig das alles ist und so weiter dann
kann man schon irgendwo nachvollziehen
dass die irgendwie dass sie dieses
mulmige Gefühl immer gehabt haben nur
damit wir hier nicht falsch verstanden
werden ne die Tatsache dass die
russische Sicherheitsinteressen
empfindlich gestört worden sind das auf
die russische Befindlichkeit keine
Rücksicht genommen wurde nichts davon ja
rechtfertigt das Verbrechen von 24
Februar richtig richtig
es erklärt die Dinge bis zu einem
gewissen Punkt aber die andere Erzählung
der sich veränderte Putin ja der
ehemalige Geheimdienst Mann der hier
Verrat wittert ja die Sowjetunion als
Kolonialreich ja das den Ukrainern kein
nie zu keinem Zeitpunkt ernsthafte
Nationalstaatlichkeit zugestanden hat
nur auf dem Papier aber nicht in diese
ihre Ideologie das ist auch alles
richtig und ich denke es liegt es liegt
wirklich der Königsweg darin diesen
Konflikt zu verstehen darin dass man
nicht sagt A oder B ja also nicht nach
dem Motto der böse Westen war es mit
seiner aus Natur auserweiterung oder zu
sagen es ist der völlig irre
durchgeknallte Nationalität sondern
diesen Prozess des wechselseitigen sich
hochschaukelns zu verstehen ich glaube
das ist eine adäquate Erklärung und wenn
ich sehe was in letzter Zeit alles für
Bücher erschienen sind die immer nur
eine Seite der Geschichte erzählen
dann denke ich mir jedes mal warum
erzählen wir nicht die vollständige
Geschichte ja der Angriffskrieg vom 24
Februar bleibt damit ein genauso großes
Verbrechen wie er vorher war dadurch
dass ich verstehe wie es dazu gekommen
ist ist er nicht entschuldigt das ist
richtig richtig Punkt nach wie
vorbereitet ja er bleibt Barberei und
nur noch eine kleine Schlussbemerkung
weil wir gerade am Anfang so viel über
China gesprochen haben es ist auch so
unfassbar dämlich solche Kriege zu
führen es ist unfassbar dumm wenn du der
Anführer eines Landes bist guck dir die
Chinesen dann das lange her dass die
zuletzt an Krieg geführt haben und alle
Länder auf der Welt die das nicht tun
das sind die Länder gibt es auch
Statistiken darüber das sind die die
prosperieren das sind die Länder die
wachsen Kriege zerstören Länder und zwar
auch die die den Krieg anfangen und
führen und das Heiraten Krieg gewinnen
genau überlegt mal der Zweite Weltkrieg
hat die makabere Pointe ja dass danach
Deutschland zur ökonomischen Welt macht
ja und das siegreiche Großbritannien den
Status als Weltmacht verloren hat genau
der wahre Gewinner des Zweiten
Weltkrieges ist am Ende Deutschland
gewesen obwohl es sozusagen die größten
Verbrechen die bis dahin in der
Menschheit vorgekommen sind begangen hat
und obwohl es diesen Krieg auf der
ganzen Linie verloren hat also es ist
Kriege gewinnen und Kriege verlieren das
ist ein interessantes Kapitel für sich
absolut wie viele Siege sind am Ende
doch kurhos richtig ne wenn dann nach
diesem griechischen Feldherrn der da in
so auch übrigens interessante parallel
zu heute ne purus der militärisch den
Römern haushoch überlegen war ja der die
ganze griechische Kriegskunst
beherrschte die das wollen folgt der
Römer damals nicht beherrscht das war
eine anfängt von oben ne hat die Römer
ein ums andere Mal verdroschen halt
immer wieder gewonnen und gewonnen und
irgendwann hat er keine Leute mehr
gehabt und dann konnte er nachdem
ausnahmslos gewonnen hatte ja sich aus
Süditalien wieder verabschieden und
zurück nach Griechenland da hatte er
verloren er hatte sich zu Tode gesiegt
daher der berühmte
muss gesagt haben soll noch so ein Sieg
ja und ich habe verloren
[Gelächter]
genau
Richard das war spannend dank dir sehr
für diesen Austausch und ähm ja wird uns
noch als Thema glaube ich lang begleiten
er dankte sehr immer sehr sehr intensiv
und inspirieren mit dir zu sprechen dann
solution ich kann das in diesem Ausmaß
nur zurückgeben und ich hoffe einfach
wenn wir es schaffen möglichst viele
Standpunkte ja als interessant
aufzunehmen und wenn wir es schaffen
nicht in entweder oder Kategorien zu
denken wenn wir versuchen zu ergründen
was ihr gerade auf dem Welttheater
gespielt wird dann sind wir auf der
richtigen Seite in diesem Sinne danke
tschüss tschüss
[Musik]
eine Produktion von m hoch 2 und Pot
Stars bei OMR im Auftrag des ZDF
[Musik]